[alarm blaring]
- HERE!
- [bleep].
- WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
COME ON.
- I'M COMING.
- AGAIN?
- STAY WHERE YOU ARE.
- WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
STOP!
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE NOT UNLOCKING IT!
- WE'RE DOING IT
AT THE SAME TIME IS THE PROBLEM.
- UNLOCK THE DOOR!
- NO.
NOW.
STOP TOUCHING IT
WHILE I DO THE LOCK!
- WHAT DO YOU WANT ME TO DO?
- JUST DO IT NOW.
- ARE YOU...
- UNBELIEVABLE!
- KIDDING ME?
- STOP IT AND RESET.
PUT IT DOWN.
- I'M JUST HOLDING IT.
- TAKE YOUR HAND OFF THE THING!
- IT IS ON THE THING.
- I GOT TO RESET THE THING.
LOOK--LOOK AT THIS.
HUH? HUH? NOTHING HAPPENS
IF YOU'RE HOLDING IT UP.
EVERYBODY KNOWS
NOT TO DO THAT
'CAUSE NOW IT'S ALL JIGGERED
IN THE MIDDLE.
IT GOT ALL JIGGERED
IN THE MIDDLE NOW!
- [grunts]
AAH! WHAT?
- TAKE YOUR HAND AWAY
FROM THE DOOR COMPLETELY.
THANK YOU.
- OH, THAT'S RICH!
YOU ARE GONNA GET--
- DROP YOUR WEAPON.
- WHAT HAPPENED?
WHAT HAPPENED, THOUGH?
WHAT HAPPENED?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENED.